7 and 8 were the correct answers. Fantastic job factoring if you got those
correct. When we start to factor a quadratic Equation we should look for the GCF
first. All the coefficients are even, so we can remove a 2. If we factor a 2
,we're left with a squared minus 15a plus 56. Now we want to find factors of 1
times 56. At sum to negative 15. This top number's positive, and this bottom
number's negative. This must mean my two factors have to be negative. Negative 7
times negative 8 is positive 56. And negative 7 plus negative 8 is negative 15.
Since the coefficient is 1 I can use these two factors in my factors. Next we
set each factor equal to 0. We know 2 does not equal 0. So 2 is not a solution.
When we solve these two equations we get a is equal to 7 and a is equal to 8.